God ever since the winds man I'm just oh
it's bad all my friends are like getting
congestion where they think they're sick
sick and I'm like it's a Santa Ana wind
the Santa antas are acting up they're
acting up just like
US citizens of the reject Nation it's me
and John Humphrey John Humphrey and me
Tera Eric we're going to watch M gar to
escape to Africa WAOW that was so good
you guys got to leave a like got to
leave a comment for that tell him how
good he is at Harmony I can't do Harmony
and you also don't forget to ring the
bell ring the bell oh my gosh that was
so good you guys give it give it a break
give it a break John Bell each time look
at him go okay listen if you're not
already oh wait no I have to thank
prepper real quick helping us edit down
these videos we appreciate you but also
you got to get on the patrion
no cuz we call you super sexy over there
so you got to get sexy you can sink up
with your own copy watch all Mas M gasar
too with me and John okay and also Greg
and John have exclusive highlights and
watch alongs over there on patreon so
just get with it get sexy also don't
forget you guys got to get shirts I
don't have one on today I'm like they
don't have this one there but reject
Nation shop these they got those ones
he's wearing it space babies of the
Galaxy and uh and other kid-friendly
shirts Child Protection Services kids
yesterday it's literally the best
T-shirt and they are super comfortable
like I love them so much I want to buy
all of them what have you got to say
John any updates or something you want
to tell the people guys listen uh uh
I've always wanted to travel the world
and this is going to I'm going to use
this instead let's do this thing in an
animated way so let's do it manacas gotu
here we
go
[Music]
I always wonder now is there like some
kind of lore or like who is that
kid Jes de boys looks like ice gold
sushi for breakfast
h love it that is a terrific little
opening button oh that poor kid they
just like they they really they got to
drop on the Works
kid oh my God he's so cute son over
[Music]
here if you're going to grow up and be
like your daddy someday you got to learn
how to fight yeah Simba is let FASA
teach you
yeah you and me are the same his little
birthmark this little Africa birth
mark ready
no Al no
dancing that is Alex for
sure Al stop stop that stop that right
no so disappointing when they don't grow
up the way you want them to my man with
the pador look on the bright side zubba
after I defeat you and take over as
Alpha Lion you'll have so much more time
to spend with your pathetic excuse of a
son that's like Al Baldwin yeah why do
you even want to become the Alpha Lion
I'm better looking I have better hair
I'm just CE inly smart and I want
everyone else to do what I say I
disagree about the hair pay attention
alaking daddy want to show you how it's
done oh heck yeah o nice dang do like a
people's
elbow
oh it's so cute I can't
oh
lurking and that Al is how you attack oh
no oh no no no he going to get lost
who's his
voice I feel like I know it but I can't
that's it here kitty kitty oh that's how
they got him damn he'll be worth a few
bucks no I hate those men and I want
them to die yeah if only this could be a
saw reaction
also yeah
wowe yeah nice got him
noce oh no I hate
it no why do we have to do
it this is wo is not what I was
expecting oh no oh little dude little
Moses little
kalell bringing in some of that Disney
heartbreaking reality at the top
[Music]
exactly oh you got a
fish fish from the sea and so the
narrative
begins
he learned at a young
age oh yeah it's in his
blood he's going to be in cats one
day looks oh my God they're all so cute
cute I think he's kind of a show off you
think he's
cute oh he was just born in that cone
[Music]
Melman oh H nice transition
not
bad I still think he's kind of a show
off you got to give it to him the guy's
an animal maybe he should take a
break we could all use a vacation come
on where on Earth would we go on
vacation I don't know about you but I
want to go to Connecticut
absolutely sold New Yorkers have
gathered at the Central Park Zoo to
mourn the loss of their beloved zoo
animals the question on everyone's mind
where are they now are New Yorkers
really this passion about the zoo in
real life there's realistically there's
two people there mourning the
loss oh my let's get all the butts all
right Bo moving
bums move it and groove it oh are are we
going to have some kind of Move It Move
It remix we must move it move it 2.0 I
can only move my shoulders as good as
they move their bums however the music
instructs oh oh my goodness nice all
right I like to move it move it he likes
to move it move it there you go move it
move it we like move it yeah there you
go this is the national
anthem if you ever come to look at
something Manhattan feel free to call
first oh my oh no caring is
sharing you can't leave without
this
hey freaks you will be very glad to hear
that I am coming with you of course
until I return with the spoils from the
new
country Stevie will be in charge get
Stevie oh Stevie I don't know if I
believe in Stevie oh no he's so
annoying the seashell or the starfish
badges
quickly get get
quick Jack clap check engine Che Cofe
check got to get your Brew
on oh no oh no no no no with the
scissors that's got to be the second
biggest slingshot I've ever
seen this is your captain speaking in
the event of a water emergency place the
vest over your head then kiss your
goodby
yes one for the
adults place the mask over your face to
hide your terrified expression from the
other
passengers that's what be supposed to be
attached to my seat no sir no sir I got
to say I put on my seat belt very loose
I never tight tight like they
say you want to be able to wriggle out
if you need to yeah oh oh yeah this is
not good it seems fun God I was so
caught oh wow that that was a a really
good um rescue no a really good fake out
yeah they had me twice first I was like
this is totally going to work and then
right when they Plum it I was like how
did I ever think this would work and now
it's working so they did it fool me
Thrice oh there something on the
wiglin little dude made
it what
oh the
budy he's going to come back he's on the
tail when we get back I might just sign
up for the breeding program whoa dating
other other other other guys oh
Melman I'm going to what is holding up
that beverage service I'm going to go
check oh buddy I want that I want that
pineapple fish shirt and there's no
possible way she's ever going to come
around to him by the end no it's not not
going to happen kids that's not how life
works this is first class it's nothing
personal it's just that we're better
than you hey I'm over H
me can I help you Mr BR my nuts on a
silver platter we just wanted to check
on the drinks we ordered so sorry yeah
Melvin's going to need a drink right
about now can you please go over there
please thank you very much whatever
happened to the separation of the
classes I'm sure this hold democracy
thing is just a
fat my God they're hitting it hard I got
to give them credit they're really going
hard on the script right now we may be
out of fuel what makes you think that
we've lost engine
one yep and engine two is no longer on
fire that was very funny I feel like
people quoted that at me and now I
finally understand the good news is
we'll be landing immediately bad news is
we're Crash Landing yep yes of course we
are we know you have no choice
whatsoever but thanks again for choosing
hair penguin always every time got that
leg
room
oh I love this Regal skeleton
chap oh my God yeah why is his
hat you are the best ever I know you
won't mind when I tell you come on tell
tell me anything tell me what I broke
your iPod
what a I'm going to kill
you now is the time for M Gloria I
always
have no
Gloria a a like like you love the beach
or or a good
book oo New York bus
baby doll you're shaking like a
leaf
up nice not bad kiss the CB just a
little Peck smooch like you're kissing
your sister what I said kiss
it I am kissing sir oh hey oh now it
looks like a bullet
train to
Africa the monkeys
hey Landing procedure flap up
deploy
hey they have awesome shots in this like
in the first one as well but this right
now the their camera and points of view
is awesome yeah it's like a real like a
you know live action action sequence
almost Happy slappers is there some
reason to celebrate look at the plane
we'll fix it I mean they did a great job
all things considered we should be up
and running and say 6 to9
months 6 to9
months 69 dud you stay with us we could
use your front cortexes and opposable
thumbs Phil I should wash your hands out
with soap oh my oh my oh boy what what
did he say that I couldn't tell from his
body
language we're stuck here hey guys as
long as we're together we'll be okay
love ain't going to get us home guys
behold who oh Bill
winter
wow oh
my I know oh my goodness she's in Africa
Bad Kitty no no oh this lady that that
purse should never have gotten through
baggage
claim C or
[Music]
whatever oh my
God she's going to live
forever she's 450 years old she's
indestructible she's a Timeless Immortal
being
Toyo
[Music]
oh
ah next time I won't go so easy on
you thank you dear my god oh man she
just gets to travel and be loved by
everyone how many punches was that out
of my mind what she got in her purse SN
out my mind now see if you can get an
operator no problem out of my mind oh
this yes
perfect yes oh oh oh
beautiful the service user has roed
outside make it look more like a
painting try again later am I
tripping wow no but yeah where are we
San Diego San Diego I think it's Africa
Africa it's got to be it's in our blood
I can feel it no no it's more than that
it's it's like deja vu like I like I've
been here before oh it's like GRS my God
is he find his dad and his dad still
alive oh my God maybe
how how oh no oh
boy me Alex me and me friends this would
be the Trope
MH I just think they bothered to go
how smash ground go
boom then here we
emerge we offer only oh this struggle is
so real I love just how much of a
theater kid he is you mean you came from
off the reserve yeah way off from the
Central Park Zoo oh
uhoh we got we got that's impossible
only people come from off the reserve
look familiar do I know you from how
could you possibly survive the hunters
it's not Bernie Mack is it does he have
a hole it is his dad okay well is there
maybe like a manager we could talk to oh
I see you're here to challenge me what
no no no oh oh the mom's going to know
oh no she knows
Al is that no it's Alex X oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah I've always had that the vet
checked it out it's really uh it's kind
of a Beauty Spot really yeah absolutely
you come home
a mom and dad mom and dad mom and dad
mom and a a
a my son you got to pick him up got to
hold him out on Pride
Rock yeah get Rafiki in here to anoint
him yeah yeah prodicle Sun returns this
is perfect oh no uhoh and I'm going to
use Sal
yes I'm going to use him to get rid of
zuba once and for all of course you are
there's definitely some Lion King love
lettering all over this but actually I
think it's actually cool that they would
do that in a way yeah Maurice I think
they like me you got to love a
non-hostile
takeover I guess you do I suppose yep
I'm Marty I'm kind of new around here
hey
whoow you like to run oh yeah run of
this
C wow C you guys are speaking my
cracking language this is this is so
hypnotic this is what if you catch a a
cold we go over to the dying holes and
we die wow oh oh my God you guys really
need a doctor hey we have an opening
would you be interested me a a doctor I
feel like you could use this sequence to
hypnotically program somebody's mind if
you just like strapped it to their face
or something yeah it's like the
throbbing pulsing things like by more
gfuel yes go to reject Nation
shop.com is M the KE is mad oh no let's
all welcome him back into the pride what
open he's going to have to like you know
show him the ropes of of being a man
real lion he's going to have to do a
whole lot of grown up this movie I think
moto moto likes you yeah oh hey moto
moto look at that brow get it oh my dude
uni brow and very strong PEC do the PEC
Flex I like
them oh my god oh my god dude moto moto
the name so nice you say it twice like
it so twice around girl it won't be hard
because you so
Plum yes body positive movie oh look at
it yeah some of the other lions were
wondering when you were going to banish
your
son if their griping about how alak
never went through the ride of Passage
blah blah blah so technically speaking
he can't be a member of the pride it's
nonsense yeah right it's in his blood
yeah nepotism fix this yeah come on now
Young Lions earned their Mains by
demonstrating their skills sort of a
show skill talent show type of deal yeah
strut in his stuff great at performance
he's going to fail in the wild in so
many ways right now good luck Al game
where I come from we say break a leg oh
that's my
boy I like that for the time
displacement his dad's name sounds
closer to Simba and then like the scar
guy sounds closer to Mufasa I don't know
yes something kind of neat about that I
don't
know that quite makes sense beautiful
isn't it yeah it's amazing this is a
good screen saver right
here operation is a oh I like that one
that's a good one it works on many
levels
sir stage one that's when I develop my
drinking
problem to Coffee
Bean oh oh
goly oh this oh nice I I know better
than to doubt these guys egg so
good go yes got y perfect beautiful the
Bon penguins are back in Action they are
I will give him the kiss of Life do it
oh we
go
oh no don't pop him oh
no classic yes Music
Boston More Than I
feel I know the words we know the
words we know the words we
know
away granny are they going to help her
dude no she's indestructible she going
to live
forever if if Michael Myers was Pamela
Vorhees that's who she would be she will
be in every Madagascar movie ever yeah
the biggest Menace to Society my handbag
man can't survive without it wow you are
one tough cookie brownies FR 416 Yas
okay you know what respect I'm not going
to stay out in the open and get attacked
by more animals
I'm too old to die yes is she going to
die right now no they I want them to do
a whole plotline about her I want her to
be a character now so badly let us see
it yeah she's going to lead the troops I
might wind up loving this they make
certain choices along the way this is
what you always slept oh
man oh it's still there this is where we
brought you on Christmas day no ends
were open so we just had this
rock is that me mhm you had the cutest
little
paw little bit old paw you did that the
day we lost you a so cute you used to
call this fofy
fyy
a well son you get your rest you have a
big day tomorrow you're going to need
all your strength oh it's going to be
such a rude awakening for these parents
other your father will have to banish
you oh boy not banish oh no you were
born with
it but he's been pampered every day of
his life since he was a
baby my son's a king this is not good
he's going to have to go on a on oh dude
quite a journey he's going to have to go
on a
walkabout oh it's people where you come
from could' you get out here can you
help us we're lost a flash of black and
white and they were gone oh no that
happened to our Jeep too what are we
gonna do how we all going to survive out
here it's gonna be Lord of the Flies out
here just let Nana do her Jambo we
survive the concrete
jungle we need food we hunt for a decent
hot dog stand am I right she's
right coffee I'm walking here Etc build
a d come on with New Yorkers for crying
out we can make it there
can make it
anywhere love that shadow Liber Lady
Liberty over
here they're just going to build a new
Utopia right here New Yorkers they get
it done you know I know
oh that's
beautiful jul oh he made
it oh my hello the Meg the mega
gascar
no sh no no I hope it could get back in
the water yeah you're going pretty far
buddy it's okay they acknowledge the
cruelty in the circle of life of this
movie this is a harsh this ain't your
grand papy's Madagascar rude awakening
for all of us what happened to our
thumbs haven't seen him since yesterday
sir on you darwi oh private you're
coming with me oh wa R you're coming
with
me chiste we've recruited a few extra
thumbs for you Skipper hey W everyone
recr up so many the monkey Army we'll
divide into three groups group Alpha
you're in charge of sheet metal
fabrication group rson you'll handle
assembly group George rard you'll handle
craft Services huh George B I got to
catch up to some of these references of
flying at at such a rate they're flying
in quick yeah I'd like to kiss you
monkey man oh all right but you're so
darn ugly yes yes all day every day love
it just remember a great dance
performance comes from the heart oh
chist from the heart you'll never go
wrong hey I like his little drama man in
my opinion the key to this whole thing
is choosing the right competitor Oh you
mean like this is like a dance battle
who do you think would be a good match
for me you know just to keep things
interesting oh if it was me out there uh
I choose teach
H TIY don't trust him he's got a streak
in his hair
yeah oh golly all
right chose your opponent oh boy oh boy
let me see H
pick
TI he got some gumps in
there somebody wake him up wake come
up what the why can't you guys just feel
like
no oh
yeah y y yep wow okay all right come on
let's do this huh come on TC fly little
TC fly come on let's see your stuff
bring it let's dance that is an ugly
buff
[Music]
line no arguments here
oh boy oh boy oh boy confusion can help
you in battle though throw him off the
scent man hip swish turn
around oh yes sir
barino oh no wow Alec hey are you hurt
oh yeah I am H you told us you were a
king and a king does not get beat I'm
the king of New York work it's it's my
stage name I'm like uh for when I
perform oh boy Al has failed the test
who would have ever imagine that today
zuba would have to banish his own
son sadly the Alpha Lion must cast out
all failures no Exposition Dice
Clay then I'm no longer the Alpha
Lion wowe a you can't do this it's going
to be a bad guy who could possibly take
zba's place yeah I this is all very
awkward but I suppose I could carry this
tremendous
burden get the
hat hat as your new leader oh that looks
like a Chita banana hat hat of Shame and
delicious watering hole for a thousand
years or life or whichever comes first
whichever comes last oh last ouch years
you should have told us that you want a
real king you never told me I'd have to
fight anybody yeah you didn't tell me
what being the King was about never
fought another Lion in my life no I
guess not you dance and other stuff huh
I mean none of this would have happened
if you were a real lion ouch
thanks this is not good there's no one
type of lion to be there's so many
different hearts and so many different
Lions swab wowe you're in my light
Steven say you this is what he was meant
to be doing as you can see I'm covered
in brown spot okay hey that bone will be
good as new in a few weeks so I don't
have to pick out a dying hole oh my God
little
dude this spot looks like witch doctor's
disease that's the most ridiculous
disease I've ever heard of Stephen whoa
don't ask I like the confidence it's giv
my man Joe our last witch doctor he had
a spot just like that mhm and Monday Joe
Wednesday no Joe ah thanks Doc so this
this which doctor's disease is no no no
no here we go at least 48 hours but i'
I've never even heard of it what I don't
have any penicillin I'm going to need a
CAT scan just to get started we'll have
a lion look you over they'd be happy to
oh my my God he was thriving just a
minute ago guys he was doing what he was
meant to be doing handle your
Neurosis oh that's nice haven't seen
that one before knocked them dead in New
York hey let's all give it a try yeah
that they're all spitting each other's
faces yeah fitting each other's mouths I
mean I got to imagine this movie cleans
up at a Furry Convention
yeah oh wow it's like a work of art
beautiful wonder if any kids tried this
after watching the movie oh
[Music]
yeah you guys got it right out the box
if you can do it we can do what's in our
blood what I always thought I was a
little bit unique we are unique oh
million points of light and dark stripes
exactly the
same exactly
the same is that true like are they all
clones or did they just all come out
with the exact same St this animated
family movie must be giving me facts
right now explain this this is good I'll
go I'll go watch some planet Earth after
this and figure it out there's something
I got to tell you hey
guys this place great or what the colors
just got like muted yeah so desaturated
I got a date with Modo Modo oh my no oh
no no you know what moto moto means
twins it means hot
hot you can flirt around with Mr hot
pants After I'm Gone what's the deal
Melman why am I the parade and you're
the rain why do you have to drive your
parade under my rain maybe I'll just
parade myself in another part of town wo
W okay why don't you just tell her you
tell what tell her I don't know what
you're talking about so I guess I'll go
then oh Gloria hey I I thought you guys
were friend come on guys Marty's
absolutely right Marty Marty Marty oh no
oh no oh this is you're not him he's oh
you thought that guy was me no no what
is happening here it's a little weird
really you guys are I mean come on Marty
so you're saying there's nothing unique
about me I'm just like any other zebra
or Alex is a real racist yeah yeah I've
been having pretty much the worst day of
my life okay it's always about you my
problems are just a little bit bigger
than yours Marty H oh Al this is no good
yeah fine run away Marty run away that's
what you do best just like back in New
York I'm right here but you can't tell
that
right okay leave I don't need you to
help me solve my problems but you do and
we'll realize that at the end of this
movie I'm terminal You Know M yeah
probably only have another 2 days left
to live no so messed up oh if I King
Julian that's my name only had two days
left to live I would do all the things
I've ever dreamed of doing like what
lovely shot to become a professional
Whistler I'm pretty amazing at it
now
yes
[Music]
fantastic job but there must be
something you want to do before you die
can't understand your
accent the bus schedule the next bus I
accent I never really had the guts to
tell Gloria how I feel about her how
I've always felt about her fine don't
tell
me what are you afraid of you're dead
man any way come on yeah you look right
in the eye you lean forward right just a
little almost all the way yes there a
lips distance away from each
other and then you just tell her how
much you hate
her that was so sensual just now you got
to rise up you hearing me I don't think
you
hear you got to
rise Julian is the
Mufasa back on the
street I would love if just his neck
extended baby i d
you yeah I'm going to do it I love that
happy little head I would love if they
actually built their Castle on the dying
pit and then like a poltergeist subplot
happens where it's like haunted because
of that relocate the bodies she loves
man she loves my thighs oh yeah she L my
roundness she that I'm chunky yes she
does she love my heess she does she love
my zestiness she does she love me
restlessly I was wondering if I were to
for example stay here I'd like to ask
you let your caned lips be the messages
to my ear canal
yeah damn it man what is it about me
that you find so interesting you are the
most plumpest girl I've ever met other
than that you know you you
junking you are failing this test sir
says something about about my
personality
Gloria
Melman
um this lips stay pursed
why too you better treat this lady like
a queen oh yes the perfect woman if I
was ever so lucky to find the perfect
woman I would give her flowers every day
and not just any flowers okay her
favorites are orchids white my dude he's
doing it and I'd spend every day trying
to think of how to make her laugh she
has the most most amazing laugh a that I
mean that's that's what I would do if I
were you but I'm not so you do it oh
good job
what who
was beautiful hey anyways where were am
I'm
huge God this is for setting me up this
is for stealing my dad's job this is for
humiliating my family and making me like
AOL I was going to say what did all
these birds or bees or whatever's coming
out of there do to
you kind of a pretty shot
though oh
every the water it's gone no The
Watering Hole has never gone dry before
oh it's a tactic I'm afraid there is
only one solution to this horrible
crisis we'll all have to fight for it
fight for it fight for it that's crazy
well that's not fair you'd win exactly
Shirley
I'm I hate him please Munga this is the
only water on the reserve if you're
thirsty you'll have to look for water
off the reserve
ouch God one dance performance toppled
their entire Society yeah I left the
reserve and survived I could do
something about this looks like a
clogged pipe I'll unclog the pipe and
bring back your water yes
ban yes know what to do where's zubba
you don't care about us zubba should be
in charge not you yeah take him down
yeah Mutiny come on
Marty music
SW oh there's no way he's going to find
Marty Madagascar 2 lost in New Marty
it's Marty in
there
Marty this is so trippy with all them
being Chris Rock if you see him tell him
his friend Alex came to say goodbye
goodbye goodbye come on
Marty what are you
doing everywhere you leave the reserve
Marty look can you leave the
Hat you've been a great friend you've
helped me so often to see the bright
side of my problems that I never think
of you as having any a I wasn't there
for you when you needed me just like
back at the zoo what kind of friend does
that make me good job alakai he's not
being a narcissist In This Moment which
is good see you in there yeah yeah you
that's right you right there 12th row 20
third from the
left you have great taste in music and
horrible taste in
friends okay I'm in no Marty you can't
come with me I don't believe you have a
choice I'm man we're doing it best
friends back together again yeah there's
only one way to get your precious water
I must simply make a small sacrifice to
my good friends the water gods in the
volcano oh no goody this is too big of a
task then the friendly Gods eat up My
Sacrifice M very nice pleas have another
sacrifice no I've had enough for
today don't want another sacrifice okay
look at you look
skinny just take the sacrifice does it
work no no I mean yes yeah it's
5050 we like those odds this is a fun
exploration of what happens in a power
vacuum who could look death straight in
the eyeball a real genuine hero I'll do
it Mel yeah buddy oh my God sacrific
yourself for the
rain Gloria I just want you to know back
at the zoo it was never the doctors or
the prescriptions that kept me going it
was always you seeing you every day
that's what kept me going no a tell him
you love
it our son has come back to us how come
that is not good enough for you what are
you saying woman woman we lost him one
subba let's not lose him again not
again oh bad guy he's coming to kill him
right now he's going to shank him or
something the watering hole is dried up
dried up that's impossible there's
nothing left you the alpha Li Aon
what are you going to do about it fix it
Al he said he could fix it he's gone up
River off the reserve no I tried to stop
him I told him it was suicide but he was
determined to prove himself to you liar
liar Marty Marty this is
it this is the clock damn oh okay I
would love it if it's beavers to
blame party stay down look at that one
D is this right oh my
God she started a village oh no oh snap
I just used my last stick this morning
where are we oh oh go people Savages
what oh I hate
[Music]
them oh
golly oh no squid maneuver go go Sly squ
and then it becomes a pea movie after
this harsh realities for the kids okay
okay okay oh boy oh my wowee that is
beautiful and terrifying Jo Joe the
witch doctor we thought you were dead so
did I then I realized I'm covered in
brown spots so's not
dying you got to tell him and then
choose someone to go in his place stop
Gloria you can't do this why not stop
for
love no oh no no it's no no run to her
run to her no run too far come on he
cannot die run melm Samar come on buddy
oh she'll get you by the horn thank
goodness did you really mean all those
things you said about me of course I did
it's crazy it
is wo it's crazy to think I had to go
halfway around the world to find out
that the perfect guy for me lived right
next door a he's he's big in his own way
you and me for the next 18 hours I'll
take whatever you got my god oh it's so
cute and it's like friends cuz they live
in the same building yeah what's going
on here might Hey Hey listen up Alex is
in big trouble we got to get up River
fast take your love and go help yeah the
plane won't be fixed until the suits
meet our demands about maternity leave
maternity leave these guys really are
our ancestors no maternity leave oh my
God maybe a certain someone wouldn't
want be blowing around on the savan
oh Scandal well well Scandal blackmail
Intrigue all right you get your
maternity
lead my goodness so much has happened
today so much what's going on where we
where we going oh oh wow going to burn
him on the steak how about a nice lion
Castle you can't eat a lion hey don't
worry it tastes like chicken oh my God
she's like the villain in the
Mist it's like uh Marsha Gay
[Music]
Harden oh
oh wowe
yes damn yeah Dad go Dad whoa dad's
coming through you got no F being out
here look at these people oh my God it's
like Beauty and the Beast but with lions
yes stay
back going to let your dinner get no no
no
no come man going to
jump the only thing I know how to do up
around the world King dance them off do
what you do
Al bars
Terra you know those moves Alex oh my
God holy [__] he's a super star even in
Africa yes New Yorkers care that much
about the zoo I like this thread he's
not dead
no how does he do
[Laughter]
that moving my
friend dad what are you doing oh hey
look at Dad he's getting down this
little swirly hand thing
yeah
it's good thing these New Yorkers God
the twirl is in his blood yay that's
where he got it from his daddy forgot
and dancing to be fair movement is
Primal in its own way it's good I like
it it tracks true beautiful now let's
eat damn it old lady you know what you
wa that's very loing tun hey Barrel
monkeys here we go he got a barrel of
monkeys she's got got a gun let's get
out while we can
Jesus she better not shoot any of those
do kids remember the have some fun and
take out the dam B it house yes cool but
it's his funeral what oh oh
goodness this is a feat of engineering
these these penguins are these penguins
are astonishing they know how to build
planes they do tell them no pull up
they'll kill us there's got to be
another way pass it
[Music]
on no up kill us there's no other way
game of
telephone sacrifice greater than someone
else oh go
medic that's a great cut Ric speed Ric
spe oh yeah oh they're going to get
clocked oh oh some cool glass POV in
this movie sorry Jambo lady yeah she's
going to survive I found you
Mor you made it oh go the shark is still
alive God it's been a minute since we
saw you oh it's going to work and of
course the timing is
perfect oh
sacrifice
achieved sacrifice accom look
Mar wow perfect
[Applause]
timing hey beautiful beautiful if I
remember correctly you quit the pride
and you were kicked out so don't think
for an instant that this changes
anything you're right in fact we humbly
present you with this token of
appreciation yeah what's inside yes I
think this would go very nicely for me
when I go out hiking but I'm afraid
you're still banished released your
inner self my friend oh no oh
handbag You Bad Kitty oh yeah here we go
the ruler the W wiie thei the the the
the arm
[Applause]
burn damn dude I thought I thought you
were the
toughest welcome to the pride you are
King now thanks St
but this belongs to you no no sir to us
a they share it beautiful
beautiful they're both strong but Jambo
Nan is the strongest that's true she is
the apex
predator love transcends all differences
and we are gathered here today to
celebrate such a love mhm true that do
you take each other for better or For
Worse yes for better please absolutely
beautiful weird couple yes that's not
going to
last hey man you never know see you
later we'll be back after the oh cool
it's a Shar plane just hitched I want to
ride in a shark plane I want to ride in
a shark plane New York isn't going
anywhere right guys as long as I'm with
her and you two I don't care where we
are so we zap it looks like you're stuck
with us for a
while ah [__] what's wrong I just
thought we could hang out a bit
and man he acts now too the teacher
becomes the student I can look into your
eyes and I know it's
[Music]
[Laughter]
you yeah get those hips
swinging get it get it it get it that's
such a pretty shot I want it on my
desktop you
rhy
sometimes oh yes hey that's a very cool
uh that's a cool title like sequence I
like that got some art to it not bad I
love it that was fun that was very fun
that was a lot that was a that was a
shotgun blast of energy but uh but
largely I appreciated pretty much
everything they did or attempted to do
yeah right especially with the beginning
like you were saying they're bringing in
the like the Disney aspect of making us
feel something and I think that was my
main
complaint possibly if I had a slight
complaint about the first one I believe
I remember talking about how there P
wasn't enough heart for me sure like and
this one they they brought it yeah and I
like that a lot yeah this one I mean
like it it was definitely like dense in
terms of like what they were trying to
pack into the script and there are so
many moments where you could imagine
like this alone is the setup for some
kind of you know like wacky exploration
of like societies and like what happens
when you're stranded amongst the
elephants and forced to fend for
yourself and blah blah how every
different person responds to that but uh
but yeah like starting off with that
sort of heaviness of like oh yeah like
animal poaching and where does zoo
animals come from and it's like it's not
about it's not like allegorically
expounding on those things like super
heavily throughout the movie but they do
like acknowledge the sort of I don't
know Whiplash nature of society and life
and just yeah like this was probably a
traumatic experience for Alex to get
here even though this certainly in this
universe seems to be a great place for
him you know and then going back and and
you know being you know with the pride
and sort of realizing like oh this these
are not the skills I need to survive
here like that could have gotten even
darker and I think it's appropriate that
they didn't go that dark about it like
it it was more about like a fight to
prove yourself rather than like hey go
kill something or whatever you but uh
but yeah like I appreciate them at least
acknowledging all these things yeah I
like that also love was involved a lot I
mean they had to bring it in where it's
like a love for like his his parents for
their son that they just refound and and
Melvin and is it Gloria it's Gloria
right melin and Gloria yeah yeah yeah
that they had sort of like they they all
made these big like um
heart that was that he was he must have
yeah I was like it was this early enough
that he could have been in it yeah yeah
rest in peace but but continue um I was
just going to say they all had these
like heart tohe hearts like big um kind
of like in a romcom where you're running
you're like I just got to tell you like
your eyes and everything that you do and
um I'm just a girl standing in front of
a boy asking him to love me um asking
him to love her that's the quote anyway
yes they had all these like heart tohe
hearts in this even with um Alex and I'm
forgetting Alex and Marty they had it uh
Melvin and and Gloria they had it but
also the parents and Alex also had that
heart tohe heart which I thought was
really sweet and nice and it had like a
little bit of a romcom feel to it yeah
and there's like it's funny in trying to
do so many things there is a lightess to
a certain amount of them which in some
ways I think is kind of nice also
because it's like you know you have Alex
very much in a story about like
expectations and and being forced into a
box and and you know having to contend
with that while also leaning into your
strengths and and it's like it's one of
those things that could have again
there's a lot of ways you could go with
that and and AR You could argue like
maybe you know you should I think like
the the experience of watching this
might vary for somebody depending on if
you want like one Journey kind of zoomed
in on throughout versus many versus
multiple plots cuz yeah certain things
get to be more dimensional like I
thought the Melman and and Gloria story
was actually like really nicely paced
because like I get sometimes you have
that situation you're just like come on
man say something but like I really
believed how they portrayed his
reluctance to do that and I liked that
they had this like really Lusty this
sort of interlude with uh moto moto or
whatever moto moto Will i Am apparently
who that was and like you know and it's
it's it's certainly lovely that they're
relishing in the sort of like oh yeah
we're both big and we love that and like
that that's that's quirky and fun but
it's also you know well-intentioned I
think that's a nice thing and then
finally his compulsion to you know
through his character through the
wackiness of his character and and
learning the witch doctor isms and
really thriving in that like all that
stuff I thought was like really nicely
paced and proportioned and then you have
Alex's story which is like you could go
a little bit deeper into into this but I
you know for what this is and who it's
for it's good with Marty I was like this
feels like it could have been fleshed
out I was a little confused as to what
they were trying to to do with that
because on the one hand it's sort of
like I guess it's kind of messed up that
Alex can't tell which one's Marty but
also Marty's like we are all the same
and it seems like they meant that
literally but also maybe they didn't but
maybe they didn't I can't tell if they
if that was supposed to be some kind of
like oh hey I don't know there's the
obvious stereotype of like people not
being able to tell you know certain
ethnicities apart you know and I was
like are we doing that for kids or are
we doing some kind of thing of like oh
you know there are a lot of people like
me out there and that can be like kind
of a troubling thing about life and
trying to figure out how you are unique
and what your purpose is and all that
like the both of those are in there and
I couldn't tell what they were trying to
do yeah I feel like I feel like probably
it's more that he he feels in like
invisible when he's around Alex not
necessarily in the wild but especially
at the zoo right it's like well they all
should but like because he's just number
one there is on his own plane of
existence yeah like maybe maybe it's
that metaphor of like he feels uh in did
I say indivisible invisible no perect
you guys I the allergies and I'm
drinking tea here and my
brain it's just it's it's rocking and
rolling and not really in all the right
ways we're coming of age it's okay we're
we're on a right of passage right now
it's a walk about shoot I forgot to say
they can cut into this right if you're
if you're listening to this on Apple or
Spotify make sure that you guys rate
this episode please and also don't
forget to buy a t-shirt go to the real
nope go don't forget to and also don't
forget to buy T-shirts and all the merch
at real reject no the reject Nation sh
re Nation shop oh my God make
sure the best ad because we're all going
to learn it together this is so good
we're going to let's learn it together
get all the t-shirts and all the merch
at reject Nation
shop.com we did it you get a free
t-shirt for that my struggle is so real
I want all their t-shirts anyway we can
continue with what we were saying
absolutely with with a completely
seamless transition no doubt yes ad I've
got it I hey me too it's amazing that
we're able to keep these as Snappy as we
are sometimes uh but yeah where where
were we in the in the reviewing um what
was I say we talking about Alex and
Marty and and and that whole thing about
feeling invisible right yeah I I was
like maybe it's that the the metaphors
worked in there and then him Alex
finally acknowledging him kind of
putting his narciss ISM to the side to
be like I know you and I will always
know you cuz you are my best friend and
at heart we I just can feel your
presence that you are Marty which was
really sweet and obviously what Marty
needed to hear initially was very
excited that he found you know uh people
that were people that he found his
people that were all the same and then
it you can get worn down by it right
like be like but what about
individuality yeah and I mean I I was
like are we going to learn about any of
these are we going to learn that not
only are you Marty like that guy's Ted
and here's what makes Ted Ted right like
that's one thing about this movie that
like I appreciate how many things
they're doing but I also feel like doing
so many things forces a lot of them to
be kind of brief which is like fine
which I'm not mad about but I I was
constantly thinking like oh you could do
this thing with this plot line and this
thing with that plot line like I I like
that they brought it so linearly out of
the last one you got the news report and
then you've got them on the boat and
then we figure out you know in trying to
escape and get back back to New York
they land you know crash land in in
Africa and uh and then we're on this new
adventure and I like seeing them all
getting acquainted and yeah finding
their people and all that stuff and you
could relish more in that not that I
yeah it's like it's not really bad to me
that they didn't but part of me is like
I kind of wish they may maybe did and
then you have like King Julian who makes
who like it has to be included and but I
thought like the way they included him
was fun and merited by the the Alec
Baldwin like you know him creating this
you know uh uh Mutiny and taking over
and then uh the water thing creates this
power vacuum where somebody like you
either have the devil you know this this
guy who's been clearly conniving for
this role for some time or you have this
new you know grifter dude rolling into
town with his random mumbo jumbo and
maybe we could follow that you know
because we're all desperate and we're
freaking out uh and then the New Yorkers
in the woods and were expanding on the
old lady and now they're like doing a
society and if if they didn't
if they just ran into like a bunch of
it's another choose your Venture moment
with the movie where you're like part of
you is expecting like maybe he'll run
into some hunters and actually have to
like tussle with some harsh realities
and we'll get like a five minute the
Revenant style sequence where he's just
got to like Maul somebody and he cries
cuz the trauma is just too much to you
know but you know not but that's what we
wanted in the first one too where they
were like well he's got to eat a steak
eventually right he's got to eat an
animal steak right yeah and you know for
who it's for I'm not upset that they
didn't go with that I'm just like you
could and and this movie did flirt with
or at least like pay some sort of lip
service or homage to just the idea that
yeah like politics and running societies
is weird and difficult and you know
various social strata are hard to you
know bounce between and blah blah so uh
yeah I don't know I I appreciate when a
movie is doing a whole lot and often
like I was always having a good time I
was always invested for the most part
like as as sort of uh ambivalent or even
maybe cynical as I was in the past
thinking about these movies like I've
had a blast watching these yeah it's
been fun yeah and I like the characters
generally I like the things they're
trying to do and I like the blend of
wackiness the Penguins you know like the
penguins are always right like and
they're always you want to believe that
they're always going to go off in some
kind of hair brained like uh scheme yeah
and they are but you I guess you always
expect it to be like janky or failing in
some way but they're always succeeding
they always yeah you're right I mean the
last one with the boat right and this
one with the plane they always they
always do it right they're the BB
Penguins yeah so I don't know yeah this
was like flipping through like a comic
book it was kind of like flipping
through like if Archie was about animals
and then like these issues are just
about these characters and then these
issues are about these characters they
all kind of loosely relate to being in
Africa you know and so like yeah I I
enjoyed it in that kind of cartoon kind
of way and I think that as much as they
did pay homage to stuff like Lion King
yeah uh you know withis and yeah reached
for maybe a little bit more
sentimentality maybe a little bit more
coming of age maybe a little bit more
harsh reality it's still not trying to
be the same experience as like a more
deep kind of Pixar thing so much as it
is still wanting to be in the tradition
of like you know slapstick and cartoon
and and all sorts of things like that
which I think is as much as in the west
animation is Pigeon hold as being the
thing for kids and that is frustrating
in a lot of ways like I appreciate when
people commit to this kind of you know
lunacy you know mixed with heart you
know yeah like they added enough heart
in this one I and a little bit more than
the first one which I super appreciate
um and it made it more enjoyable for me
yeah because I really I wanted to see
what was going to happen with him and
his parents which was great um I would
give this one yeah I'd give this one
like a seven out of 10 yeah it's not
like these the they're not my favorite
like animated movie by any means there's
still like as I said with the first one
I am very much drawn to the to the Pixar
Vibe just the the art of their
storytelling um a lot and uh but this
one I think number two I did enjoy more
than one cuz there's still a lot of
Comedy there was a lot of there's a lot
of plots going on but I did appreciate
that CU it kept it it's always very
entertaining and it doesn't this one
didn't seem um like the time was like
ticking by and I don't think I felt that
one in the first one this one just
seemed quicker moving which gradual yeah
yeah which I liked it kept me more
engaged sure yeah and I I I like the
contrast of that I think is appropriate
it's like the first one yeah it's like a
little more it's still like a bit mad
cap but yeah it's moving at like a more
steady Pace whereas this is like firing
off in all directions yes uh and and you
know you've got like a Alec baldwood for
as like menacing and and villainous as
he is like is is easily vanquished in a
moment you know so yeah like uh yeah it
definitely though yeah it keeps you sort
of you don't have time to lose focus
you're on to the next thing yeah yeah
exactly and uh oh I had a I had a ribbon
to put on that and now I don't remember
what it was maybe it was your rating
what you rate it probably what did you
say like a seven I said a seven yeah
yeah like 6.87 seven depending on yeah
depending on the enjoyability you know
maybe even a 7.3 look at him go you know
wow there are ways in which this could
be even greater but for what it was
nothing made me mad I was always having
a good time I was always enoy enjoying
myself pleasantly even if I was confused
as to what they were trying to do you at
moments uh yeah yeah solid for what this
is uh you know mission accomplished they
did it well all right do you have time
do we can we do a patron shout out let's
do um what's a good like Safari or or
something that matches Madagascar that
we can do two patrons like uh okay if
they're stranded in the wild maybe yes
okay so I want to give a shout out to my
Patron AK super sexy
reject uh we just watched uh yeah we
just watched Madagascar 2 so much harder
to type fast escape to
Africa and we want to
imagine these two
patrons uh stranded in the wild and
having to survive
together uh and work in a dancing animal
somewhere that's great and make it cuz
we did this with Greg and it rolled
three pages so tell it to be yes how
many words be like in under how mean how
many like 100 words 300
200 75 words5 keep this to 75 words I
feel like 50 words could be a little
short but maybe 75
and then okay the last part of this is
we got to pick the perfect two patrons
who belong in this scenario uh all right
pick a name you like oh any name you
like any name okay I like I like Leach
okay and I like Perry all right Mark
leech and Brian Perry here we go yeah
let's do this thing uh one and a two and
a three whoa here we go wow creating
Imes oh my God this is creating images
this is going to be like a fullon thing
oh no Terra what do we do I'll download
these you'll download the images and
then you'll get to see the images and
what is happening right now those images
will be here's the oh my God it made a
digital art piece featuring you guys'
cartoon character stranded in the in the
wild African savannah it says working
together to build a
shelter joyfully dancing zebra is also
included in the scene we hope you enjoy
the adventure this picture needs to live
on for forever for both of you I have no
idea if this is even what your faces
look like I I sort of don't think so I
might blur them on screen this image is
lovely but could you do it as script
with only dialog uh in 75 words in 75
words or less oh my God oh my God this
is certainly here's a short dialog
script here we go cat
the stranded in the wild Bri Perry Mark
Le strand of the wild with dancing
zebras I'm just going to preemptively
tell it to rewrite this in more words
okay who do you want to be okay I'll be
Mark and zebra okay look at this place
Brian we're really stranded but we've
got each other and hey is that a dancing
zebra welcome to of The Wild
Friends oh right I'm Martin unbelievable
this is the adventure of a lifetime
let's build a shelter together we can
handle
anything agreed let's do wait am I I am
Mark oh my this is what happens when you
take on two roll it's too much for me
agreed let's do this team and don't
forget to dance a little yes excellent
let's see what the expanded addition
this you guys need need to plan a trip
now uh just to absolutely here's the
expanded version of the scripts all
right I'm going to be mark this time
Mark gazing running ah Brian can you
believe it stranded in the heart of
Africa it's Wild Mark but look on the
bright side what's that over there hello
new friends welcome welcome to my Dan
floor I don't know if it's problematic
to do Chris Rock uh the African Savannah
uh ooh a talking zebra dancing zebra
this is incredible only in Africa Africa
right Africa but first we need a game
plan shelter yes let's build something
Teamworks our best uh bet out
here I I'll provide the entertainment
twirling he's twirling dancing eases all
worries uh Mark I think that we got to
make something out of these absolutely
Brian we are a great team and with our
zebra friend here we are un unable I
felt you going to say it don't forget to
enjoy the moment guys let's dance we
won't forget we won't forget let's get
to work and maybe learn a few dance
moves and that's how Brian Perry and
Mark leech brought dance back to the
United States of America to our patreon
where we gave it to the people and
turned the world color from monochrome
thank you so much thank you for being
here and for being super sexy we'll
catch you on the next one bye
[Music]
bye